the student academy award seems to be
very good to scandinavian countries this
year as our gold medal award to a film
from as our gold medal award goes to a
film from the norwegian film school
i might add that this is a first time
win for norway in the student awards
directored by directed by halvorwitza
the film tuba atlantic tells the story
of oscar an elderly gent who upon
receiving a terminal diagnosis
attempts to reach his estranged brother
in new jersey
thank you
this is uh i mean i i i i i i
i tried to prepare a speech but now it
seems like doesn't matter i
i i guess i just kinda
speak for my heart um
i try to be cool and hold my tears back
but i think i'm gonna fail so um i just
gonna say thank you um
my fantastic great fantastic crew i have
a i have a sexy voice but this is just
awful
uh
lynch the net my writer gudrun the
fantastic producer uh carl eric one of
the most talented cinematographers in
norway
sulfrid
uh the the uh the production designer
nils jacob your fantastic and vessel
editor
you're all fantastic and every part of
you every blood and and time we spend on
this film is shown in every frame
and i'd love to
sorry i'd like to say uh thank you to
you ingrie which is the actor the young
actor that was 12 years old when i found
her and i'm sorry i throw
uh fish intestines on you and uh that
seagull i i i did mean it but i i told
you perhaps
it's a good time to say i'm sorry and of
course my my wonderful parents uh i
it started early and i i thank you for
your
bravery in raising me i'm sorry that i
broke your camera in 1992 it was because
of some things with gasoline action
scene and a gi joe and
that's why it didn't work and i'm sorry
to admit it uh
20 years later
and i don't know how to express myself
but i have a choir the tube atlantic
choir
and i just want them to help me express
my feelings so if you would like to sing
for me and the academy award as a thank
you to the entire industry and
my fellow filmmakers that will make me
feel so great so please guys
you